ja vielen Dank wir haben vorhin das
Thema auch schon ein bisschen
angesprochen es geht um das von der
andere geplante Verbot ab 2024 also in
einem Dreivierteljahr fossile Heizung
einzubauen also das Verbot von Öl und
Gasheizung das ist etwas was die
Menschen extrem verunsichert ich kriege
jedenfalls als Bundestagsabgeordneter
unheimlich viele Zuschriften dafür weil
die Menschen sagen wie soll ich das
eigentlich machen das überfordert mich
wirtschaftlich ich kann das am Ende
nicht ich bin vielleicht gerade in den
Ruhestand gegangen bin Ende 60 ich habe
einfach nicht das Geld viele 10000 von
Euro zu investieren wenn das ist nach
der Vorgaben nämlich so dass man in
allen denkbaren Konstellation
wahrscheinlich eine Wärmepumpe einbauen
muss und es reicht eben nicht nur eine
Wärmepumpe einzubauen was alleine schon
viel viel Geld kostet sondern man muss
wenn die ökonomisch sinnvoll betrieben
werden soll am Ende dann auch noch die
Fenster dämmen man muss möglicherweise
eine Fußboden einen Heizung einbauen und
vieles auch mehr und was mich in
besonderer Weise jetzt da geärgert hat
dass die Baumeisterin äh klarer Witz das
von der europäischen Ebene jetzt geplant
wird da geht es auch um
sanierungspflichten das ist von der
deutschen Seite von Robert Habeck auch
sehr vorangetrieben worden dass sie
jetzt sagt das sei alles
verfassungswidrig das ist ein Eingriff
in die Eigentumsrechte sie aber
gleichzeitig auf der nationalen Ebene
beim Gebäude Energiegesetz also bei
diesem ölheizungsverbot nichts dagegen
tut sondern ganz im Gegenteil diesen
Entwurf Mitarbeiter hat das ist aus
meiner Sicht wie Gott unter verliert die
Ampel und die Politik in Gänze dann am
Ende Vertrauen Glaubwürdigkeit wenn man
die Menschen auf diesem Weg des
Klimawandels nicht mitnimmt und sie
dabei überfordert Hallo gesagt das ist
ja auch aktuell ein einfaches Thema für
die Union und Punkte zusammen ich glaube
laut neusten Umfragen ich habe über 80%
der Bürger finden das auch nicht gut was
da passiert aber wie realistisch ist
denn der Vorschlag überhaupt
also das ist ja umgesetzt wird es ist
nichts was jetzt mal eben so aus der
Schublade gezogen worden ist sondern die
Ampel hat sich auch schon im
Koalitionsvertrag auf genau das geeinigt
es ist jetzt sogar vorgezogen worden
dass man gesagt wir müssen schneller
werden und das ist natürlich auch
richtig wir müssen im Gebäudebestand
Vorankommen bei den sanierungsquoten um
dort mehr CO2 einzusparen aber es nutzt
uns ja alles nichts wenn wir die
Menschen auf dem Weg nicht mitnehmen
wenn die Menschen am Ende des
wirtschaftlich überfordert und sie am
Ende nämlich genau das machen was jetzt
eigentlich schlecht ist und das ist
jetzt gerade passiert durch diese dieser
Dröse Kommunikationspolitik der Ampel
von Robert habe ich momentan stehen bei
den heizungsmontüren die telefonisch
nicht still alle Leute versuchen jetzt
noch auf den letzten Metern noch schnell
eine neue Gasheizung eine neue Ölheizung
einzubauen damit es dann möglichst noch
20 oder 25 Jahre hält und das ist
natürlich genau das Gegenteil von dem
was eigentlich richtig wäre es ist ja
vernünftig stärker zu gehen auch gerne
in Richtung Wärmepumpen das kann aber
auch ganz was anderes sein
technologieoffenheit müssen wir waren
das ist alles in diesem Gesetz nicht
vernünftig vorgesehen und das ist glaube
ich der Zentrale wir müssen am Ende ein
durchdachten Vorschlag machen aber ich
halt jetzt auf den letzten Metern noch
gesagt naja wir wollen das ja irgendwie
auch fördern aber es gibt kein Konzept
dafür und wenn wir den Menschen ins
Schaufenster stellen ihr müsst das
machen das kostet euch 50.000 60.000
70.000 Euro sehr schnell man hat aber
nicht gleichzeitig eine Antwort darauf
wie man diese sozialen Spannungslage
auflist dann funktioniert das nicht
wiederholen sich das ist überhaupt kein
Problem aber ich will einmal weitergehen
an eine Löffler und zwar ist die
natürlich meine Frage was hätten sie
denn von dem Vorstoß von der Arbeit also
grundsätzlich muss man sagen dass ich
würde das gar nicht so sehr auf die
Ampel projizieren weil es kommt ja
letztlich von der Europäischen Union
also es ist jetzt kein rein deutsches
und kein rein äh rot grün gelbes Thema
fakt ist nur wir müssen natürlich
irgendwas tun also wenn wir das ewig vor
uns herschieben dann wird es nicht
gelöst werden dass man das natürlich
nicht auf die ähm Haus Eigentümer
Hausbauer komplett abwälzen kann das ist
klar grundsätzlich wird es aber nicht
dadurch gelöst werden dass wir Anreize
schaffen dann dann die Klima das Thema
Thema also es ist es geht halt immer
nicht wenn wir jedes Jahr sagen aha es
ist so trocken und wir haben irgendwie
die Ausbildung der Klimakrise aber
selber sagen wir wir müssen es irgendwie
also wir könnten ja wir müssen es noch
weiter wegschieben die Politik und die
EU sind natürlich gefordert dass selber
auch natürlich zu finanzieren das wird
ja auch schon in Aussicht gestellt dass
dann mit finanziell unterstützt wird
aber wir müssen wir müssen das machen
wissen sie welchen Anteil Deutschland am
Klima weltweit hat sicherlich relativ
großen
2,8 % sein also deswegen wir sind nicht
der Player der der den Unterschied
machen wird aber ich will trotzdem sagen
also unsere Verantwortung ist als
Deutschland das zu tun was wir können
und deswegen müssen wir darauf
vorangehen wir stehen ganz und
zweifelhaft zu den CO2 einspazieren die
müssen wir auch erreichen wir streiten
aber über den Weg und ich glaube es
zeigt der deutlich das was die Ampel
jetzt macht das ist eben ein Fehlanreiz
wenn die Menschen jetzt Gasheizung
erneut einbauen dann verzögern wir die
notwendige umwand und deswegen wäre es
eigentlich viel besser das was wir jetzt
schon haben Emission handelt CO2 das
heißt als Instrument als
marktwirtschaftliches Instrument zu
nutzen man gibt einer Sache nämlich dem
CO2-Ausstoß einen Preis und dann können
sozusagen alle Menschen die Industrie
die Unternehmen darauf reagieren was ist
für Sie der beste und der richtige Weg
aber so wie es gemacht wird erreicht man
genau das Gegenteil momentan Fehler man
merkte die Menschen haben Angst um ihr
Haus dann hört man jetzt gerade ja auch
die Zeit 2,8 Prozent und da fragt man
sich ja schon ob auch mit der Angst der
Menschen vor dem Klimawandel gespielt
wird um auch Politik zu machen
mag sein klar ich unterstelle immer das
Robert habe ich das tatsächlich so sieht
dass das ein Kern Anliegen von ihm ist
und uns alle auf diesen Weg zu bringen
und er hat wie gesagt in diesem
Interview sehr deutlich gemacht dass er
uns das nicht zutraut aus eigener Kraft
heraus das zu machen das nach seiner
Ansicht der Staat das regeln muss sonst
bestellen wir alle Gasheizung und zwar
nicht nur jetzt sondern auch nächstes
Jahr und über nächstes Jahr aber was
sagt hier gesagt hat fand ich super
eigentlich diese Thema
Technologie technologieoffenheit das
wird nämlich überhaupt nicht gemacht man
kann natürlich auch Gasheizung einbauen
die gleichzeitig auch wasserstofffähig
sind und einem dann die Möglichkeit die
Brücke in die Zukunft bauen das wird
aber negiert weil weil habe ich gesagt
nein also das will ich nicht vielleicht
kommt er noch dazu die Preise vielleicht
noch ein Punkt dazu da wird ja immer
drüber gesprochen ja es kostet 15000 so
eine ist auch sehr sehr viel Geld
natürlich so eine Fußball so eine
Wärmepumpe
dann sagt er aber es gibt 20 % Förderung
hier 40 % Förderung da und unabhängig
davon kosten sind aber doch sehr viel
höher sie haben es angesprochen der ein
Häuschen hat dass er vielleicht mit 63
Jahren abbezahlt hat und das jetzt
finanzieren muss der diese 15.000 dann
hat er auch noch er muss eine
Fußbodenheizung einführen dafür um im
ersten Stock eine Wärmepumpe tatsächlich
zum laufen zu kriegen Wärmepumpen Strom
betrieben ne wenn es kalt wird auch noch
umso mehr Strom das kostet 43 bis 50
Cent pro Kilowattstunde also das sind
enorme Kosten die Dämmung haben sie
erwähnt aus der EU und
das sind Kosten für jedes Haus von
100.000 Euro und wer hat die denn und da
finde ich auch muss man sagen auch die
SPD in der Pflicht und ich sehe sie
überhaupt nicht wahrgenommen zu sagen
wir wir geben auf diese Menschen zu der
einzige das macht ist denn diese
sächsische Ministerpräsident Stefan weil
aber und wir reden auch mal offen über
das Problem aber auch in diesem
Interview unterfragt auch keiner Robert
habe nach den Kosten er muss so eine
Frage gar nicht beantworten es bleibt
immer bei diesen 15.000 Wärmepumpe viel
Geld die waren Kosten sind viel höher
und das muss man auch irgendwie lösen du
hast gerade Olaf Scholz angesprochen
Sarah das vergisst man ja auch leicht in
der Debatte wo halt habe die haben mir
einen SPD kannst ja Olaf Scholz der ist
doch eigentlich bei dem kleinen Mann da
soll die SPD doch sein oder obwohl
kleiner Mann übrigens auch schon
bescheuert ist ja eigentlich sollte es
so sein meine erinnert sich ja noch an
die Barbara Karte Respekt für dich von
Olaf schon und gerade wenn es um Geld
geht bei den Bürgern sollte auch dieser
Respekt eigentlich da sein ich meine wir
hatten ja jetzt auch Corona und jetzt
die Energiekrise den Leuten geht gerade
nicht so so ganz so gut in der Tasche
und es ist so für mich ein bisschen
typisch grüne man möchte natürlich am
liebsten sofort Deutschland Klima
neutral machen ja am besten morgen und
dafür kommen dann ganz viele Verbote ja
der Verbots Hammer in dem Fall war es
der Heizkammer und denkt dann gar nicht
über die Realität nach was das bedeutet
wie es umgesetzt wird was das kostet was
das für die Menschen wirklich bedeutet
und für so viele würden sie abgezockt
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie